this just a brief intro of uh what I do
and why where I
work so the primary the overview of it
it will be divided into mostly
understanding of the part that what un
learning is uh why we came here and how
we arrived here at this stage that uh
with the recent uh development with also
the recent cost security Bridges
everything and then uh how are undering
Frameworks are developed or what things
needs to be considered while uh building
something or while deciding any forget
any forget making systems for getting
certain things uh how to evaluate such
systems uh how to test them so
evaluating the sense that the same
evaluation criteria we normally use in
anyl algorithms the same evaluation
criteria and a lot more on top of that
and then there comes comes the
verification in the sense that what the
things that we made the model unlearn is
it unlearned or is just there it's not
showing uh something like that so that
through two parts of the verification
part also be uh explored
here so the first question that comes
into mind that why we came here why we
need to do why need why we not cannot
just retrain why we need our learning or
in the first sense why we need our
learning in the first sense at all so
the first thing is the Privacy part uh I
just included one uh portion for the
Facebook privacy policy change just for
uh understanding of what I mean what
happened and why same included the
iCloud photo the hacking part uh
scenario
itself and then the came the right to be
forgotten regulations as well as the
multiple regulations including the
including in FTC rulings recent FTC FTC
rulings as well as the gdpr rule
uh gdpr Provisions as well as the
proposed canadi year law provision as
well on the same part that uh certain
elements certain informations is cannot
be just be deleted from the databases
cannot be just deleted from sto data
storage systems but the influence of
those items the influence of those
systems has to be also deleted from the
products that the companies are selling
as well because our data is not just our
data which just merely sits on a on a
hard drive somewhere somewhere it is uh
actively being trained on the inferences
intelligence is actively being extracted
from and then uh new business
development business ventures have been
getting getting developed from there so
that but the last part that the data is
not just mere data itself that is where
the right to be forgotten regulations
came into picture and uh the need for un
learning or making things forgetful or
making machines forgetting informations
became Much More Much More Paramount
second part is security obviously it is
is security but the security is not just
privacy related security but security is
related to the robustness of the model
itself because we have seen uh uh
certain injection based attacks on the
certain models on certain systems itself
including uh spam filters and uh even uh
simple polygraph simple warm detection
algorithm itself so uh the idea that uh
a certain uh bits and pieces of
information certain bits and pieces of
samp of Records can be introduced can be
injected and the underlying base model
can be corrupted has been quite
frequently uh published has quite
frequently referenced as well so the
security part became very much uh
prominent in the whole conversation on
the uh model for forgetfulness and the
ear learning of the
model and third part is the usability so
for example consider the recommendation
system or any recommendation engine be
it's sptify Netflix or anything I think
most of people who have joined has that
has experience that if you give if you
lend your account of Netflix or someone
else's and they they watch some word
where uh shows uh your Netflix
recommendation gets messed up so that
also comes into picture in the same part
itself that how to retrain it how to
make the things much more
forgetful and the second part is the
same conversation is why for why are
learning why not just retain it I mean
uh if you just retain it it will be much
more easier much more much less headache
so the next part is that cost Associated
to anything related to any production gr
systems so I just added uh one par
one cost on how to on cost related to
training uh large parameter models uh so
on the right side on the graph itself
you can see the pictorial uh
representation that how the cost has
like almost linearly and then
exponentially shoot shoots up so you
cannot just me untrain uh retrain a
model just at the whims of some at the
whims of an uh click so the there are
certain there are specific cost ass
associated with it which makes the whole
process very cumbersome as well as uh
business wise quite uh quite costly so
that is when the what uh the UN learning
part comes into
picture so uh the current research space
as such is as such how we came here is
not new in the sense that it's not just
now that people started working on that
people have been started working on that
for a long period of time so the initial
decremental based learning systems were
there like uh 2003 2004 uh which were
primarily for cardal based or svm model
svm system svm based
models uh then the traditional machine
learn machine learning term was
introduced I think in 2015 uh so that
that paper that paper give an
understanding of what machine learning
is what certain paradigms to treat and
then uh C and then the basic framework
of that then we went to 2019 which
introduced some probabilistic ear
learning probabilistic feature into the
whole ear learning Paradigm
itself and continuing from that that
same probabilistic nature had then
theoretical error boundness into the
model framework to make people to make
people some give people some
understanding of the uh theoretical
error boundedness of all of any uh
machine learn learning
framework and uh till now till I think
till this paper itself till this stage
itself most of the work has been done on
uh linear models linear linear models
ltic uh regation
models very few work was done on deep
learning models itself but that also
started changing I think from recent
from papers I think from starting from
20120 itself so a couple of papers
couple
of really good papers I have uh
referenced here if anyone wants to go
through them uh just to see how the
space evolved how where we started from
and how we came at the stage uh this
would give a brief understanding to them
just by reading couple of the follow
this timeline how we arrived at this
stage so uh the first part that comes is
the challenges what are the challenges
that normally developers or researchers
faced while while looking into the uh
paradigms of the learning Frameworks or
any ml un learning Frameworks How uh
what kind of things they need to
encounter what kind of things they need
to take care of like so first thing that
comes into into mind is the stock atic
because any ml algorithms is stochastic
is is nature so the training process is
also becomes stastics in nature in the
sense that when you train a model you
just don't train it for one single batch
the data sample is not from one batch it
is from it is present in multiple
subsamples multiple sub batches as well
so how to remove influences of all those
uh of of that single in from all those
batches that is the one of the biggest
headaches then comes the incrementality
part of the system that
the specific item there specific samples
which is being asked to be forgotten uh
influences which is coming after it and
it is also being influenced which is
coming before it so that incrementality
part that the smooth lar flow also gets
broken if you just uh pick something up
then throw it away so that also was
is one of the biggest headache these two
are one of the biggest headaches while
in building any kind of un learning
Frameworks
itself the third one is the uh
catastrophic un learning in the sense
that you can just unlearn a model but at
the end of the day if the model doesn't
perform well if it's absolutely if it's
absolutely bad in the sense accuracy
part anything uh then there is no point
of making building those are learning
models itself the framework itself you
can just retain it and because business
wise you need that system itself in in
place but the our learning part made the
system so unusable that the accuracy is
so low that it is not servic it is not
filling the promises of the business use
case so that is the last part of the the
unlearning accuracy or cat catastrophic
uh nature of the unlearning process that
it can it can go bad and sometimes it
can go terribly bad from the model
performance uh robustness itself
so the general framework of uh un
learning un learning model or making a
system forget something uh is somewhat
starts with the pre-t trade model where
uh the model which has already been
developed either prop or inh house tra
or something like that uh there is a
specific training data set I can be very
specific to domain specific or can be
Fair's general purpose but there is a
training data set but then you have the
UN learning part introduced where is you
you have a forget full forget data data
set where might be a single sample needs
to be forgotten from the simp from the
data set might be a class of sample
might be a feature set something like
that and then uh then there comes the
evaluation metrics part that how how
would you determine that the model that
you have the UNL model is it good enough
is it good enough to be redeployed again
is it good enough comparing to the
previous one how good enough it is and
the second and the uh foremost part is
how long does it take like the whole
efficiency pass part how long does it
take to our learn it is does it make
sense to just retrain the model itself
if it is taking too long to unra unlearn
it so this this is the basic framework
how I un learning how I uh normal uh
forgetful systems uh move
around so the design requirements of the
previous uh of the previous diagram uh
corresponds to or translates three
different parameters that everyone looks
at uh or everyone takes care while
developing something so first is the
completeness so uh so the prediction
that the system is making how good it
the predictions are compared to the
previous one in the sense that if the if
it a simple uh if it's a
simple uh it's a simple uh binary
classifier uh image based classifier how
good the systems is compared to when the
system was full in the sense that
there's no learning there there is no
systems data were not removed or
something something like that that
constitutes the completeness and if it
if possible how worse how worse it is
also compared to if you just retrain the
if you had just retrained the model
itself so these two things two parts
accuracy wise constitutes the whole
completeness part of the Paradigm that
how complete is the unlearn model is it
worse it is is it better or is it
somewhat considerable then the
timeliness part in the sense that same
efficiency Parts comes into picture that
how long does it take to finish it it
might take couple of minutes it might
take more than time more than the time
that it actually took to develop the
model so actually train the in in
actually took to train the first model
itself so timeliness comes into the
picture because at the end of the day
the system needs to be efficient while
in while if any production system needs
to be efficient and the process the mlop
part itself also needs to be efficient
so that the systems of the ml models are
deployed quickly uh given certain
business requirements or use cases
itself and then the third part is the
verifiability for say you have there is
a ear learning for say considering this
diagram itself there is a un learn there
is a model already there the model that
certain data sets has certain samples
has been removed the influences has been
removed but is it actually moved is it
verifiable how
much how can you verify those certain
things so that is the part this three
are the primary it's like a triangle
part that these three are the primary
corner stores while uh designing any un
learning framework so these are the
primary uh design uh
elements uh then comes into the picture
that the what kind of removal request or
what kind of REM removal can be done so
if I go back to the initial slide itself
you can see the forget data set can be
single sample uh I mentioned here item
wise just a single sample from the data
set it can be a feature so for say
consider a scenario where it has been
noticed that the certain feature of a
model for for Simplicity purposes
consider a uh classify itself uh spam
filter itself uh email spam filter
itself consider a certain feature wise
that if C uh a certain feature needs to
be uh
needs to be removed or the influence of
certain features needs to be forget uh
then how would you uh take how do you
take that uh request into the into the
whole conversation itself because the uh
Fe when you talk about features you have
to talk about whole whole data set
itself so whole training set itself
whole validation set itself whole
testing set itself so that feature wise
uh classification that feature wise
removal is one of the trickiest part
while considering this kind of scenarios
and then the classwise so if you are
considering any kind of if you're if you
are encountering any kind of uh
situation where you have to look for
biases uh you have to look for certain
certain biases uh related to uh gender
race something like that then also the
classifies removal is one of the biggest
one of the most important removal types
in that sense that you want to remove
remove certain uh class from the whole
data set uh from certain class from the
training data set something like that so
that classwise uh our learning or class
classwise removal uh becomes one of the
uh largest uh becomes one of the most
frequent removal request in fact uh on
on whole production scale not just
individual scale itself in most cases
the individual scale the itm wise
removal is most of the times that is uh
noticed then the comes part in the
verification and evaluation phase so
this is the part that I mentioned in the
in the last phase that once you have the
Learned model how do you evaluate that
model is good is it good enough uh the
model actually will perform or even
whatever un learn un learning happened
or the machion system actually for
forgot is it did did it actually forget
or it is just false
positives so uh I just uh added uh uh
most of the use most of the used methods
for verification and evaluation metrics
I'll will not go through all single one
of them I just pick two from
verification and evaluation so uh if you
just look at the evaluation metrics it
is the same accuracy uh accuracy
Learning Time same kind of metric that
you use but then uh lot more is added on
top of that uh considering uh the kind
of evaluation that you are trying to do
is not just determining if the model is
good enough or not or if the model is
trying to predict good enough or not
that is just one at least 10% of the
whole part then the comes into the
picture that how long it takes what is
the completeness how good it is or in
the sense that uh if you have changed
for say if the model has changed uh if
it's a if it's a deep neural network how
the weights change over time so
something like that so the evaluation
Matrix also changes uh quite drastically
and the verification part is not verific
verifying uh is the the model
performance itself the the verification
part is verifying is the model actually
forgot what it's supposed to forget so
it is not uh indication of the puff how
how good the model is but rather how
robust the model
is so uh I'll just pick two part two uh
verification method from here and two
From Evolution metric so the first one
is the feature injection set test so
where you uh I add actually added the
paper as well when it was where it was
first uh referen first mentioned so uh
two of the most useful or use cases are
Fe first is the feature injection set
where you add a feature Set uh which has
high cor which has very high correlation
or more uh more specifically direct
correlation uh with the Val with the
samples which is supposed to be forgot
which is supposed to be forgotten and
very minimal almost tends to zero
correlation uh to the rest of the data
set so what will happen is uh
you will see the change in weight quite
drastically while uh change in weight
quite
drastically if you introduce a single
feature for all the samples where uh the
the cor the correlation of the feature
is quite high for uh the set that is
supposed to be forgotten so the weights
uh so the model weights uh supposed to
change in the sense that not supposed to
change model weight will change uh quite
drastically and if you just plot them
before before and after you can see that
uh the weights has actually uh changed
and then you get some I I understanding
or some indication that the system is
performing differently considering that
the uh metrix the accuracy Matrix are
still okay are still acceptable uh then
you have the verifiability of the model
that okay the model is actually actually
have forgotten but it was supposed to
forget and next then I think this is one
of the
uh uh use um one of the most talked
about uh adversity attacks as well so
the membership inference attack so this
is where
the uh uh model uh this is primarily for
the uh usefulness of the model of the
model itself where uh it the model uh
supposed to forget uh certain records
and the change in weights between the
layers has changed so that is where the
membership inference attacks comes into
picture uh the I think okay uh so the
last one is Al is almost done the last
one is the evaluation metric so what
kind of evaluation metrix is used uh to
determine if the model is good enough or
not in the sense that is it usable or
not uh it has nothing to do with the
verifiability of the model it has
nothing to do with to determining if the
model has actually forgotten or not it's
just to determine the model's
performance uh I I'm not I am not
explaining the other parts that I
mentioned here
accuracy uh and Z Source everything I
just I just adding two parts two metrics
uh which is which is different than the
other which is different than the other
normal machine learning development
Parts itself so the layer wise
difference distance so this is this is
where uh the distance between the
weights between the layers uh changes
quite drastically uh to make the model
indistinguishable among each other the
evaluation Matrix the accuracy might be
same but the layerwise distance the
jakar distance between the layers are
quite are so different that the models
are indistinguishable between each other
uh considering that everything else has
worked considering everything else is
identical so this gives a good this
gives a robust understanding uh if the
model has actually is different than the
previous one or is it just a simple one
a simple uh same same probability same
everything as the earlier one so this
layer wise distance the layer distance
between the layer the weights and the
jaar distance this gives a pretty good
understanding and pretty good uh refence
for that uh and the second one is the
ear learn Ty so you might have built uh
a robust framework with a good uh with a
good Evolution metric is in place to uh
to understand if the model is performing
well or not and then uh to understand to
actually have an understanding of the
verifiability of the model also but if
it is taking too long time then the
efficiency will come into picture that
how long the model is taking the how
long it is taking to learn then if the
if it's actually taking more time then
it will be just it will be just
economical to just retrain the model at
all like why would you unlearn it when
you why would you build something to
unlearn unlearn a model if it is taking
too long so this two Fe these two parts
uh targets two specific dimens to
specific scope of the development one is
the distinguishability between the two
models in the sense the model previously
and the after the model forgot so first
one targets a distinguishability between
them and the second one targets the
efficiency is it actually viable to
build to un learn the model or to build
the framework
itself so this is a uh very brief
understanding of a brief overview of the
whole uh machine learn learning par
Paradigm there are much more things in
there uh the whole uh learning algorithm
how to define them how to even Define
metrix itself uh I couldn't go I think
almost out of time uh couldn't go over
them uh yeah uh I added almost all of
the references in the slide itself uh
yeah that's it thank you